foreign
welcome back everyone to another highly
educational episode of careful boys wow
Z we have Kristen Farina with us today
hello Kristin welcome back Kristen hey I
saw a really interesting statistic and I
wanted to see what the statistic for
this was in this room okay
53 of people admit that they've hooked
up with an X
oh yeah yeah with the next [__] yeah
have you guys ever hooked up with it I
just talked to him yesterday how to
dress up like French maid what the give
me blow sex from every angle possible
what you reap the rewards dude not true
I haven't oh then the statistic is
arrived 53 so one of you guys
well not gonna be you yeah I have so
that's true interesting well actually
it's 50 because it's three and three
what's the story of how you did it oh a
lot of
but like in your kindergarten names
but how like what's what's what happened
what do you do how did this even
well I would say one time I try to break
up
okay yeah and then she came over with
rice krispie treats and I was eating the
rice krispie treats and then we had sex
and I said damn it she got me the Rice
Krispies and then we got back together
because she you know Rice Krispie treats
and a [__] is kind of hard to say no
to and then so yeah and then we got back
together and then and then we broke up
after but she was an ex at the time oh
okay yeah but how soon after you broke
up was the next hookup
when we did it again yeah it's probably
within a week oh that's very sure it was
like I break up with you
and then I'm like okay but okay so then
then Mo then I would say none of them
counts because oh they're all like that
they're all like that what what it's
like these [__] are making rice so no
it's not always like that but it's like
that's it we're done we're not talking
anymore sometimes they don't make them
they buy them I'm sorry yeah yeah and
we're done right and then so it's like
and we're done oh that's still gray area
and it's like can I come pick over my
pick up my stuff and I'm like yeah sure
you could have your stuff and then they
come over and then it's like oh I miss
you so much yeah
[Laughter]
but there is one um where we where we
broke up and literally like it was about
a year so it was maybe a year and a half
that counts maybe yeah something like in
between over 12 months for sure how did
that re how did that like reconnect
how did that reconnect [__] I forgot
these were like re-flurting one day
I totally forgot yeah wow yeah I don't
know how that that one came to be this
was right this is around College
yeah so
did you go to college yeah I went to
college
I did two years of junior college and
then I started my own business started
working that and I went back to college
for another two years so I'm finished
yeah so it was in between there it was
quite a blur what was your gap of time
um four months
that's pretty good absolutely and we
were definitely broken up and like you
know hey lion insane bye-bye and all
that [__] oh is that the one yesterday
um
mad that you were dating up yeah but
then she didn't do blowies and I was
like you're [__] on the way out
ah
Brad you know set your boundaries yeah
hey a man's got to know his limitations
that's what cleaning yeah that's and
he's a great man I believe in that
and I think I'm using the quote right I
think I held it with the quote that was
the only time he'd never do that with
another person or the model didn't come
back later with a new skill no because I
told her off too hard the email to the
email yeah you broke up on email you
cold dog she emailed someone and tell
them they don't do blowies I didn't tell
her that part yeah most professional way
of breaking up in the like at least
mostly yeah now go yeah to whom it might
concerned
I I believe that that um brevity is a
solo wit and that would have been much
better than what I did remedies the solo
yeah in that situation oh my God instead
of Conor [__] saying her mom I hope her
mom dies or whatever I said yeah which
was petty you gotta hit hard that's how
you feel you know there was um so the
girl that uh my one of my first
girlfriends I would say like I was 16
and we lost our virginity to each other
and uh we were together for maybe like a
year
six years later
we started talking again but not in that
way we were just like discussing like
where our lives have been and how
different we are and then we started to
talk about the subject of like
hey we really didn't know what we were
doing back then like should we try again
do we know what we're doing now second
shot yeah and it was very much like a uh
what how different would it be you know
with what we know today yeah yeah our
skills are way better yeah yeah it's
always cool we um yeah we hope without
any kind of like romantic connotation of
like we didn't want to get together or
anything yeah or like do that whole
thing but we did just feel the same well
yeah we did meet up and then we did try
it again and it was great
and then I found out she had a boyfriend
at that time
yeah and when did you find that out
crazy right after during you tell him
yeah no would you ever tell if like you
found out someone was in a relationship
no no I mean the person that cheated on
me with you mean like that no like if
you hooked up with someone then you
found out like they had a boyfriend I
mean I think that's more of a girl thing
what do you feel about you know the
girls that will hire other girls to DM
their boyfriends to see if they'll catch
the bait I think that's a little psycho
it's pretty funny but I think it's funny
but it's psycho yeah it depends maybe if
you're suspecting something I don't know
if that's the best way to do it but yeah
I see all like tick tocks and stuff like
that it's like oh hire this hot girl the
DM my boyfriend and then like how fake
are those videos they're so fake it's
insane true right it's like the most
wooden acting ever I don't think so I
was a better actor in high school
somehow somehow yelling yelling to the
people in the back row
projecting is what they call it packing
out acting outside the pocket the entire
time being a complete hack
yeah that is really weird to do that but
also like if you're that suspicious then
maybe you're just not happy in general
yeah yeah look at those views but it was
cool that I think that was the only time
that I ever did that
but it wasn't like you're getting back
with her no no it wasn't it wasn't like
a romance thing at all we just were
really like because we stayed friends
and I mean we just wanted to know
because we were kids like we were both
16 and we were both like super nervous
super not sure how it even works
and uh I wouldn't mind that if I was
single I would I would be like hey if
you're if they're if they're single
because that would be weird if you find
out later and you're like oh you have a
boyfriend
yeah I think she was also when she told
me she was like yeah it's not working
anyway so he's on his way out and then
they did wake up like right after so
what was the verdict
the verdictable the verdict of was it
the same or wasn't it it was it was
amazing it was awesome but if it was
that good didn't you go um damn man I
want to get that again and then maybe
another like in a three months and then
maybe can we just keep meeting good
missing what was missing yeah no it just
I think because we both genuinely really
just wanted to know that just try yeah
then you're both like nah that's cool if
you're on the same page yeah you don't
have like an attached because Bill Gates
has his arrangement with his ex it's so
sexy when he was when he when he was
with this um girl yeah with this with
this Melinda Gates Foundation yeah
do it once a year he gets to meet up
with his ex is this on the website no
this is like a real thing this is a real
we did a whole story he's not even being
completely full of [__] right now yeah
yeah usually
usually create a lot of things yeah this
one it's true yeah they show the house
where they hook up oh that's cool
beautiful house you know what excuse he
told Melinda he goes no one can play
Scrabble like her
what that's great yeah that was his
excuse like there's Scrabble like no one
no one knows me the way she does and
then like they talk and then they play
Scrabble oh okay but they're weird yeah
I think it's just talking about [__]
and then you get to throw [__] later but
but
with the Scrabble letters yeah yeah they
spell it out yeah yeah this this uh this
x of mine she's the girl that remember I
told you guys a story about how we lost
the condom and I couldn't find it oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah like months all
right damn
months yeah until she went to the gyno
and she didn't know it was in there and
then the gyno had to tell her is her
body having like reactions to it no she
was she didn't have any reactions so
like I remember one of the champion ages
ago when I first told that story and
like nobody believes it in the comments
so I hit her up and I was like hey watch
this video and she watched it it was
like I cannot [__] believe you told
everybody
send me proof yeah I screenshotted our
conversation but I can't believe you're
making this up so hard I know I'm just
so dedicated elaborate that's crazy yeah
but she's the levels of this wouldn't
the smell like if she takes off her
pants like it was like clear rooms and
like basically kill human beings and and
birds it was a bad smell she said it was
it was bad yeah I wasn't there this is
like the latex is just oh do you have
any animals dying randomly or that
she's had a lot of yeah she had fish
just turning upside down animal
casualties man oh gross but yeah she's
the one that we decided to try it again
and yeah was it magical or was it
awkward at first was it like oh we're
like we're like good friends that just
pick up where we left off I think that
like when when it's like someone like
that it's different like we were each
other's first so it's like there's a
level of comfort yeah I've never been
uncomfortable like I'll talk to her from
like time to time every so many years
and then we'll just like
shoot the [__] and we're just super you
know it's like nobody knows me in that
exact same way so but we're not like
attracting each other at all it's just
like hey that's it is what it is if
you're not attracted to how you get
horny I mean I'm not attracted to her
now but that was when I was like so 16
is when we were together and 22 is when
we re-hooked up
and 22 is still like 22 You Don't Have
To Be A Champion
thing happened 22. how was that when the
con thing happened you were 22. 16. that
was the first run so he had to do a
reset because he was like remember that
time we kind of ruined it with the
condom yeah you gotta give it some air
yeah we only had sex like a few times
and we're like what were we even doing
yeah yeah it can't get worse and more
Awkward than that yeah yeah and that's
and that's great because you're both
awkward so it's like you know I think
you're just gonna start a movement of
like people like can I get a redo
like they're gonna call back and be like
can we yeah let's run it back yeah I
think that's can we get a can we get a
replay like a do-over if you're that
honest when you ask I think you're very
successful I came so fast back then like
please I'm so much better now like I'm
like three full minutes not one dude
yeah it's three minutes dude it is it is
pretty cool but not like one one
thousand to one thousand lives no like
real seconds like one two three four
five six seven eight yeah
a guy who does auctions for a living
foreign
that's a funny thing to like be
braggadocious about in that way like
watch how long I last now six years
later six years later I used to
premature ejaculate when we were dating
but now oh boy I think that's a little
flattering don't you think
what is it's for the lady not for the
lady you know if you you pretty much
ejaculate she's like damn I gotta type
that's true that's true but they could
run it back they can run it back if they
if they you know gather their not me
I mean I'm gonna take a nap yeah yeah
yeah yeah mix like go for round two and
I'm all like nope I'm going to sleep
yeah yeah yeah cause you and me here in
that situation
keep going and I'm just like
uh I'm sorry I'm gonna can we take a
rain check or I owe you I'm gonna say
yeah dude come on Joe you guys you guys
have never hooked up with an X has an X
ever come out the woodwork to kind of
and you know that they're trying to kind
of get you're trying to fish what does
it sound like please it sounds desperate
can we just try again or it sounds like
you're you sound that sexy yeah it's
sexier
pretty pretty pretty
um like they're too interested in the
thing that I'm doing now that they know
nothing about it's like okay you sound
like you have an example so you've been
like directing right like whoa like I
know we've been together for like five
years and you've been directing the
whole time but like I I I think it's
time I want to listen to it
like tell me a little bit more
or it's just like the constant
um hey what's up good morning
communication of just like the small
talk or just bugging YouTubers yeah yeah
oh yeah that's how you start really
started yeah you've never been all your
stories or something you've never been
like five percent no usually when that
switch flips off it's off I feel the
same way when I'm when I'm not
interested in something like for me is
just like
if I have to be like emotionally
connected to you for that to even happen
so if that's if that switch is off like
it's probably not coming back on you
don't you you you you you don't seem
like a very hook-up culture type of
person what do you say it like that
dude culture culture yeah like you don't
just casually you're not just throwing
that thing around yeah no not like it's
a bad thing but there's some people and
it's not bad it's like it's great if
you're you're throwing a thing that
thing yeah because there's dudes that
throw that thing Colleen's not about
throwing that thing that thing around
dude for the right person
a T-shirt cannon she's throwing Tom
Brady darts she's getting guys walking
away they're just trying to walk away
they're doubling over throwing an atom
T-shirt cannon to the top yeah bro yeah
to the mezzanine
um what's the duration of time when they
start coming back around is it like
immediately when you break it off or
whatever and or do they ever break it
off and then they come back around like
actually I think I made a mistake I
think sometimes when you get into a new
relationship like I've had that where I
got in a relationship and then like old
people are like hey how are you I'm like
it's always good how are you doing yeah
how are you done wait so after you get
into a relationship they come yes like
seeing oh like you know someone I used
to date and then see me with someone
else it's like hey hope you're well I'm
like I'm great
really I don't know any guy that says
that so if they do that's us
hey how are you you know Hi how are you
dude nothing gets my [__] drier than
that you guys ever asked me how you've
been together
yeah bro I'm drying up hearing that oh
yeah inauthentic yeah I've known you for
how many years right hey how are you Joe
how's everything so your mushroom
business taking off what the [__] you
want [__] I'm not [__] you anymore
[Laughter]
how are things man so June B huh so you
and Hannah seem pretty serious
[Laughter]
sexism in the past
but it's still awkward I think Nick's
trying to [__] me again I think he's
trying to rekindle an old flame and it's
something right through me dude yeah and
I don't like it that's cool like it's
cool that you and Hannah are like
reactive kind of doing your own thing
you just seem really happy you just seem
like in a different place I saw that you
liked the same video I did on Instagram
I kind of felt like we had more of a
connection but like I don't know yeah I
guess that's cool though I'm happy for
you I guess that's so awkward if like
right after a filming day you text him
and you're like hey we were really
vibing back there huh
I'll text it to Joe but I'll
accidentally send to the group and I'm
like oh
[__] do you want to go to a separate
chat
just kidding guys you know me I always
respond to the group chat
Nick is like yo I felt like a personal
energy coming from you but like I don't
know if it just you know was just me but
we were making a lot of eye contact but
you would say bye to me by being right
are you mad at me the Synergy was there
but I think aside from that we had a
special one I'd be like you I feel like
Steve was just getting in our way of
ours
this is so weird yeah let's stop dude
what's the topic
even know that they [__] do this [__]
because because we all read fanfic yeah
every last one of us I had his when I
was in high school when I was I was
talking to this one girl for a little
bit and like I was like in love with her
for like no apparent reason but I was
like really into her and like she told
me like yeah we should stop talking and
I was like oh okay and I was like
heartbroken for a while for sure and
then I I was like really mad at her and
we shared a locker or something and I
was like and I just was like now I ain't
talking to you bro and I was like going
out of my way to be really mean to her
and because I was really mean to her and
I was just trying to hurt her feelings
she was like hey what's up like how are
you nagging yeah like dude it [__] it
kind of worked watch Pick Up Artist
videos it [__] worked kind of but and
then we we like we we hung out again and
then I was like nah this is not this is
not cool I don't like this that's a
that's called it that's called a double
whammy double whammy
his ex right now like hey he's pulling
up the conversations but I've never had
a situation like that where I'm like neg
her get her to come back yeah say no
double whammy so Joe if I'm like really
mean to you just know a while yeah
because then I start feeling insecure
like oh he doesn't like me I have to be
nice to you I think I have to be nice to
him for him I think I hurt his feelings
I really don't want to be here when I'm
at the point I really want to be here
the day that you start nagging Joe to
get a reason shut up you ugly [__] stop
talking to me it's getting hot
oh god dude I don't get it like dude if
any of us I don't get it he's different
he's different it's not like him he's
not like other guys if Beneva shows up
here earlier and these guys are actually
wearing each other I'm just gonna laugh
let's go back
at that point
Ricky's under my coverage oh [__]
dude oh [__] sick dude and Ryan's like
hey what's up Joe oh and I'm like hey
Ryan Hey Joe you sweat Hey Joe you're
sweating a lot it's not even it's cold
in here what's going on
hey Ryan
that's 20 minutes dude that's it no no
no you just finished it's like turning
off the camera oh I'm just checking I'm
just like checking the camera
switch cards switch cards
Nick's like don't worry Joey just shave
my mouth in my little chin area so when
I eat your butt out it's not gonna
tickle too much are you smooth
You're So grizzled when you say it Ryan
comes in like I saw Nick's car outside
I'm like oh yeah I think I think he's
taking a walk yeah
oh man hey I want to do that first
man
went that way
all right dude we gotta delete this
video
oh
thank you